eine mogelpackung ist für viele menschen
paul auch derzeit josua kimmig weil sie
sagen moment mal der stellt sich jetzt
hin sagt er lässt sich nicht impfen und
alle die ins stadion wollen müssen 2g 3g
geimpft es ist alles kompliziert und
jetzt haben wir jemanden der für viele
auch eine vorbildfunktion ist und sagt
ich lasse mich nicht impfen ist das eine
debatte die wir aber dennoch jetzt
gerade brauchen das ist eine sehr sehr
wichtige debatte weil es am ende zur
aufklärung beiträgt was mit impfen
wirklich sache ist in deutschland ich
finde allerdings ist findet gerade eine
hetzjagd gegen herrn chemiestadt
sicherlich das war kritikwürdig dass er
sich sozusagen für eine corona
impfkampagne hergegeben hat aber selbst
nicht geimpft war das kann man
kritisieren aber wenn man sich das mal
anschauen in den sozialen netzwerken auf
twitter bei instagram da wird kim ich
jetzt hingehängt und gesagt wie kann er
nur jetzt muss er aber und er soll sich
impfen nein es ist in deutschland immer
noch die freiheit jedes einzelnen ob er
sich impfen oder ob er sich nicht impft
und jetzt kann man das kritisieren was
du sagst dass es diese 3g regeln gibt
aber ich finde es ist nicht im einklang
mit dem wie wir in der gesellschaft
debattieren sollten wie kimmig dort
momentan ja beschimpft wird und auch von
allen angegriffen wird uli deppendorf
zum beispiel der ehemalige ard
chefredakteur der hat gefordert dass der
fc bayern handy mich rauswerfen soll
also dann würde ja bedeuten kein
ungeimpfter mehr in der bundesliga auch
kein ungeimpfter mehr vor hd-kameras
möglicherweise kein ungeimpfter im
bundesjagdgesetz den tweet einmal einmal
anschauen der den molli dettendorfer
gestern raus gefeuert hat bei twitter
und er ist dann auch
zulage geworden also hier sehen wir noch
mal wo er sagt warum spielt der
ungeimpfte joakim ich immer noch in der
mannschaft von bayern münchen bis zur
impfung sollte ja nicht mehr aufgestellt
werden also und dann die frage zu
stellen was ist wichtiger vorbild oder
profit er wohl letzteres also welche
debatten da aufgemacht werden bei der
frage ob sich jemand im tor nicht und
das ist finde ich wirklich ein echter
corona impf pranger der da von einem
ehemaligen hohen und angesehene
journalist der ard aufgestellt und weiß
natürlich crazy ist wenn die zuschauer
nicht rein dürfe weil sie ungeimpft sind
und runden auf dem rasen spielt dann in
einer mit in der wichtigen rolle daten
gibt absolut ich bin der überzeugung
dass sozusagen man auch getestet ins
stadion gehen sollte und dass diese
zweijährige
grundsätzlich ja dass man über die
grundsätzlich nachdenken sollte aber ich
finde der umgang mit jemandem wie joshua
kimmig wirklich unmöglich ja und wenn
man sich anschaut wieder auch der
debatten ton ist und die leute gar nicht
mehr aufhören auf ihn herum zu hämmern
dann finde ich das wirklich sehr sehr
schwierig zumindest gibt es sehr sehr
viele menschen die hadern mit der
impfung die sich nicht ganz sicher
fühlen wir uns einmal genauer anschauen
welches die gründe dafür sind warum sich
die menschen in deutschland derzeit
nicht impfen lassen wollen und das geben
sie an 61 prozent der befragten
ungeimpften stimmen zu und sagen ich
möchte das streben nach profit der
globalen impfstoffhersteller nicht
unterstützen also hier wird angenommen
es geht mehr ums geschäft als um die
gesundheit 67 prozent stimmen zu bei dem
satz ich fühle mich von erwartungen der
gesellschaft und politiker unter druck
gesetzt also ein aspekt den wir hier
jetzt gerade auch gesprochen haben
dieser druckte entsteht das gefühl ich
kann ich selber darüber entscheiden ob
ich das machen möchte und die mehrheit
derer die sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen geben an ich glaube co wird
impfung ist möglicherweise nicht sicher
genug und ich glaube das ist die
wichtigste zahl über die wir reden
müssen die anderen zahlen glaube ich das
sind auch noch mal zahlen die zur
diskussion stehen aber diese mehrheit 74
die sagen ich fühle mich damit einfach
nicht sicher alle informationen liegen
auf dem tisch wir bemühen uns auch in
dieser sendung darum diese informationen
zu liefern zu zeigen was sie kann ja wo
man und weise immer in unterschiedlichen
formationen gartner das muss man ja so
ehrlich die frage
wann sich da hinstellt und sagt ja alles
liegt doch am tisch na ja es gab
reichlich verwirrung auch von ihm ich
glaube es gibt da einen mix zum einen
gab und gibt es in deutschland schon
immer menschen die skeptisch gegenüber
impfungen sind ganz generell und sich da
auch festgelegt haben dann kommt dazu
dass durch das internet durch soziale
netzwerke
verschwörungstheorien zum beispiel viel
viel schneller greifen als in der
vergangenheit und dann glaube ich gibt
es auch so eine gewisse sturheit in der
bevölkerung zu sagen nur weil die kanzel
oder politiker zu mir sagen ich solle
mich impfen lassen mache ich das noch
lange nicht und dann das glaube ich wird
genau in die falsche richtung dieser
druck der teilweise erzeugt wird also
dann wird über 2g gesprochen in
österreich zum beispiel wird bereits
weichen lockdown für ungeimpfte
diskutiert und das ist ja etwas in der
vergangenheit haben wir häufiger erlebt
was in österreich ausprobiert wurde kam
dann ein bisschen verspätet auch nach
deutschland das kann ich mir mit der fdp
in der regierung kaum vorstellen dennoch
muss man sagen also der druck hat
bislang zumindest in den bereichen nicht
zu dem ergebnis geführt der druck hat
nicht geholfen aber auch informationen
oder bratwürste haben das ja nicht
geholfen da bratwurst warten ja schon
wir haben wir gesehen dass dann geben
wenn ich mich bei kimmig hilft
vielleicht dann eher und so in der uli
hoeneß daher an der quelle sitzt mir
vielleicht ist ja doch noch mal mit